now what my woman I have a perfect day  apparently that perfect wedding day is  going to cost Kevin Hart and everything  she says to me all I go yeah that's  great it's gonna be nice  how much oh man that's great dude oh my  god I can't wait to see it  how much Oh what are we gonna have this  this is so amazing that knows of it how  much but it's all worth it you know why  because there's the woman that I love  and I want my woman to have a perfect  day that's what any man should want you  see how I just turned that around ladies  just notice it the ladies are bound to  melt when Kevin teams up with dwayne  johnson in their new movie central  intelligence but too bad he couldn't  score a spot in the rocks  Baywatch reboot I tried but they  wouldn't let me go nude nude I said to  new BAE looks like a nude beach yeah I  said look man I said my trucks got to  come off if I'm gonna be in there I'm  trying to do a different type of slow-mo  run they said no no Kevin Kevin